me
web ムービー
[音楽]
[拍手]
こんにちは
皆さんは何か言語を学んでいますか
なんなら英語と外国第二外国語で何か学んでいると思います
では何のために学んでいますか
治験のためですか
留学のためですか
就職のためですか
好きだからですか
私は今まで英語と韓国語とポルトガル語を学んできました
英語は
学校の試験のため
韓国語は留学のため
ポルトガル語はブラジルへ行った時に生活に困らないために学びました
ではもう一つ
皆さんは誰のために学んでいますか
話せるようになりたい
コミュニケーションが取れるようになりたい
私は少し前まで自分のために学んでいました
皆さんはどうでしょうか
ここで一つ言語にまつわる体験談を話します
ブラジルで日本語教師をしていた時に2週間の休暇があり
南米を旅することにしました
旅をする時にネックとなるのがやはり言語です
ブラジルの公用語はフォルトがある子ですが
ブラジル以外の南米の国グリの公用語はスペイン語です
必要最低限のポルトガル語なら何とか理解できていたのですが
公用語であるスペイン語は勉強したことがありませんでした
しかし
最初の訪問国パラグアイデー
ak 路へいい
どこどこへ行きたい
あボール
何々を一つくださいなど簡単な会話なら
ポルトガル語でもなんとなく通じたのです
面白いことに相手の話すスペイン語もなんとなくですが理解できたのです
どうしてでしょうか
実はポルトガル語とスペイン語は兄弟のように似ていると言われています
どのぐらいにているかと言うと
とてもを意味するポルトガル語は6んと
ですが
援護ではむっちょです
私ものもう意味するポルトガル語は
単弁ですが
スペイン語では単元です
似ていると知識として知っていましたが実際に通じたという経験を通して言葉は
つながっているんだと実感しました
そして机の上の勉強だけでなく実際に離されている国へ行くことで言語の面白さを知り
ました
日本人にあまりなじみのないポルトガル語とスペイン語ですが世界でいったいどれだけ
の人たちに離されているか知っていますか
世界で一番多くの国々で公用語として話されているのは英語ですが
実はスペイン語も
スペイン中南米20以上の国や地域
約4億2000万人もの人々によって話されています
ポルトガル語も
ポルトガルブラジルアフリカ諸国など約2億5000万人もの人々によって話されてい
ます
国は違えど言葉が通じたという経験を通し
世界が広がりました
通して人生の選択肢にスペイン語やポルトガル語がなかったんだろうと思いました
もし
話すことができたらもっともっと多くの人たちとコミュニケーションがとれたのに
でもそれってみんなも知らないのではと思ったのです
言語を学ぶと3つの良いことがあります
一つ目にコミュニケーションが取れることです
二つ目にその国の文化やその国の人たちの考えを知り
より深く相手の仕事を知ることができることです
私は現在
出雲でブラジル g に日本語を教えています
授業では様々な言葉を教えます
例えば
食事の前と後にはいただきますとごちそうさま
でしたご馳走様ですと言いますごちそうさまでしたと言いますが
これは生き物や生産者の方
料理を作ってくれた人
全ての者に対する感謝の気持ちを込めて言うのだと説明をします
授業の始めには先生のリスペクトを込めて
宜しくお願いしますというのだと説明します
ちなみにこれらの言葉を直接置き換えることもできるポルトガル語はありません
もし外国人が日本語を勉強したら私たちの考えをより深く理解できるのではない
でしょうか
逆に私たちが他の国の言語を学べば相手のことをもっと知ることができるのではない
3つ目に
言語を学ぶ楽しさを知ることができることです
ブラジル人の生徒たちは苦労しながらひらがなおぼえ
カタカナ覚え読み書きができるようになり
職場の日本人が話すことが理解できたとうれしそうに報告をしてくれます
会話や文字の読み書きは人と人
人と社会をつなぐコミュニケーションの手段ですが
それを学ぶことは喜びでもあるのです
自分が外国人という立場で2年ブラジルで生活をし
ポルトガル語ができなくて苦労した経験や
悔しかった思いがあったからこそ
日本に暮らす外国人の大変さがわかります
あの時の経験があったからこそ周りの人に目を向けることができています
生きていく中でつらいことや苦しいこと楽しいこといろいろありますがいま振り返って
思うのは楽しいことよりも苦しい時の方が得ることが多いことです
何をしなければならないんだろう
自分は何がしたいんだろういろんなことを考えます
そして学ぶことや得ること本当にたくさんあります
もし皆さんが今嬉しい立場にいるとしても
その状況日か
するのではなくそこから何かを学び取りましょう
それは必ず皆さんの力になります
そして今までの経験で得たことを周りの人に与えてほしいです
ある日
知り合いの方から
本陣向けにポルトガル語講座を開いてほしいと声がかかりました
日本人にブラジルのことを知ってもらうチャンスだと思いましたが
自分一人では難しいと思いブラジル人の友人に講座に参加してもらい手伝ってもらい
ました
その講座は今日本人とブラジル人が出会う素敵な交流の場となっています
その後も地域のイベントでのブラジル文化の紹介や料理の販売など
自分一人ではできないこともみんなの協力により
できるようになり
多くの人たちに彼らのことを知ってもらうことができました
人と人が出会い新しいことが生まれ
みんなが笑顔になる
言語を学ぶことで幸せをシェアできることを知りました
そして日本人とブラジル人とコミュニケーションが取れることは私の大きな武器となり
ました
もう一つ
皆さんに言いたいのは
チャンスは目に見えないということです
チャンスは無言で通り過ぎてしまいます
もし
ポルトガル語がわからなかったらそのチャンスにさえ
家つかなかったと思います
ポルトガル語ができたらからこそチャンスを掴むことができたのです
だからチャンスを掴むために皆さんにはいろんなことに挑戦をしてほしいです
そのなかの1つが言語を学ぶことでもあるのです
何か言語を学んでみましょう
自分の知らない世界に一歩足を踏み入れてみましょう
知らない世界を知ることは
自分の視野を広げる抱くことだけでなく可能性を広げることにもつながります
そして自分の目で見たことを感じたこと学んだこと
身につけたことそれを周りの人と分かち合い
伝えてほしいです
言語を学ぶことはあなた自身が幸せになれるだけでなく
周りの人をも車線できるのです
ありがとうございました
[拍手]